all right Kenneth is where the skill is
in VA in VA of course Virginia would be
what that's called hi can you mr. Ramsey
I'm doing very well how are you better
than I deserve what's up well first I
wanted to say that I've followed you
since I was 18 and I'm 26 now and it's
really just giving me a leg up on most
other people who aren't doing it my
whole life and I just really appreciate
it my question for you is do you have
any advice or thoughts on investing into
re I t's not the publicly traded time
but private re I t's like rather than
investing a stock ah
they run the spectrum from really really
bad to awesome
and so I can't as a category say oh yeah
it's great you know but you would really
want to do a lot of due diligence a
private one scares me more than a public
one for a beginning investor because
whatever money you put in a private one
you need to be prepared to just forget
you have that money it's probably very
illiquid you're probably not going to be
able to have access to the money for a
long time in order to get the best
returns and you really need to be in
with a group who is not milking the REIT
for their profit through expenses
thereby leaving nothing on the table for
the investors and in the early days even
the publicly traded reach did that to
the point that for years we couldn't
find a REIT that had an average annual
return of over 8% in the public traded
side nowadays you can find them that
beat the S&P that are north of 12% now
not all of them do but there are some
good ones that are actually beating the
SP and would probably be a pretty decent
investment for some people really
interested in that the private ones just
leave you open to you know you just got
a lot less transparency a lot less
insight and a lot less liquidity it's a
very difficult to get out of them once
you're in them early and so if you need
to if you need to get out of a
publicly-traded it's just like selling a
mutual fund use so it you're done and
there's a market for it privately true
private ones are again many times not
always but many times very difficult to
do so I would want to do a lot of due
diligence on a private one I'd want to
really know what was going on in the
inner workings of it as best I could I'd
want the track record of the players
other deals that they have done where
they didn't milk the investors because
the problem with Reid is they can run
the management fees up and they take all
the money put them in their pocket and
there's no profit and so the investor
gets no profit and there's no cash flow
out of the thing
and so you can you can milk them they're
not that hard to milk and so you've got
to be with solid people that have a
proven record of passing the money on to
the investor if you want to play with
that then it need to be money you could
burn if you do that then I'd be okay
with it